This is Anthony. He's a sales and
persuasion expert that I coached live on
stage. And there are seven things that
he did without even realizing that made
him come across more cold, too polished,
and less approachable. And after 15
years of coaching millions of people to
improve their communication skills,
here's what I've learned. Even the best
communicators have blind spots. And
what's inspiring about Anthony in
particular, even though he's already
such a great communicator, he still
invested time, energy, and money to
further his abilities. Anthony's going
to show you what masterful communication
looks like with his story first. Then
I'm going to break down the blind spots
that even he missed so that you can see
them and learn from them. Check out this
guy. I freaking love him.
>> Hello, my name is Anthony Vizzari. I
help people get better at communicating
in a way where they don't feel salesy or
pushy. I'm speaking on stage and I see
right at the back a client I had closed
12 months prior. He's sitting at the
back. As soon as I finish, I see him
come down the steps. He's walking back.
He's locked eyes with me. He comes up to
me. I thought he was mad at me and he
said, "Anthony, I have a bone to pick
with you." I said, "Hey, Naval, what
what's going on?" He said,
"You saved my life."
First, I took a breath. He wasn't mad at
me. He didn't want to bash me.
But then I said, "No, Naval, you're the
one that grew your business. It was all
you." I just downplayed it. He's like,
"No, no, no, no, Anthony, you don't
understand. You saved my life." He said,
"12 months ago,
when we spoke over the phone,
I was suicidal."
He said if it wasn't for that
conversation, I don't know where I would
be today.
And in that moment,
I stopped and I took a breath. I was in
sales. I didn't really believe that I
was doing something good. I thought that
sales was a bad thing, that I was doing
it to people.
But when Naval spoke those words and he
said, "You saved my life."
In that moment, I realized the more I
actually met the needs of others, the
more I sold to the needs of others,
the more my own needs were met.
Where selling isn't something you do to
somebody, selling is something you do
for somebody.
So, I realized in that moment that I had
viewed myself as a salesy person was
actually taking away my ability to
connect and sell to the people that I
could generally change their lives. So,
I want to leave you with this. Whether
it's sales, whether it's communication,
whether it's persuasion, whatever it
might be, how do you view yourself?
And how does that need to change in
order for you to live the life that you
truly want?
Thank you.
>> Well, that was amazing. So many things
you did well. I love the pauses. My
goodness, can you feel the pauses now?
You can see when he slows down his rate
of speech, building it to a moment of
crescendo. So beautiful the way you're
moving on stage as well. He's moving
with purpose. Right? And then the
client, one of the biggest mistakes
people make is they just move around for
no reason. He's moving with reason.
Beautiful. What I'm about to share with
you is some fairly high-level advice now
because you are very an extremely great
communicator. Do you mind if I share a
few thoughts?
>> Please.
>> Okay, thank you. I'd love to. Otherwise,
why would you be here?
>> Yes.
>> The first thing is when we communicate,
we all communicate with certain rhythms
and cadences. The rhythm and cadence you
are sticking to is one that is of a
coach archetype.
And it's a strong archetype. Very
important archetype. Most people are
afraid to go into the coach archetype.
You stayed in coach.
So, what happens when you stay in a
particular archetype is that it feels
very strong and at times it feels like
I'm at you a lot. You feel like if I'm
staying at this, do you notice how that
makes you feel?
Do you notice how if I stay in this
presentation mode, it makes you feel a
certain way? So, what I want you to do
in a moment
is have you been through the program
online?
>> Yes.
>> Okay, fantastic. So, I want you to think
about
>> by the way. Little plug. Do the program,
if you have not.
>> Correct answer.
Correct answer. Thank you. So, what Link
in the description.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah, that's right. If you want
access to that free 2-hour training,
remember the link's in the description,
or you can scan the QR code, as well.
Back to the video.
>> So, what I'd like you to do at this
point is Again, it's not to do with the
story, but I want you to break away from
coach just for a moment. I mean, like if
I asked you right now, "What did you do
for break What did you do this morning?
What did you do for breakfast?"
>> I didn't eat breakfast.
>> Oh, you didn't?
>> No, but
>> Cuz cuz fasting?
>> The reason I don't eat breakfast is cuz
one of my rules is I don't actually eat
before I speak. So, that's one of my
rules.
>> You see the way he spoke just now?
That's friend archetype. Because the way
to be the best communicator you can be
in this life is you learn to speak the
way you speak to one,
the way you speak to many. That's really
the thing I want you to play with. So, I
want you to come out, start the story,
but be in friend archetype. Begin walk
out, and here's another tip I'll say, as
well.
Often, what we do is we start talking
while we're walking.
Don't talk till you you get to where you
want to be. So, you walk out,
and the beginning and be in friend
archetype. And make this the button
where you start doing friend archetype.
In three,
two,
>> It's 2018, and I'm finishing my degree
at the University of South Australia.
This was going to be a really big moment
for me. I was about to graduate and do
my final presentation.
>> Pause. Do you sense that? Do you feel
the difference? By softening coach,
going more into friend, you establish a
connection before you go to coach.
>> Mhm.
>> We don't start with coach straight away,
because uh unless you're at a sales
conference and you want to fully go into
coach, but that's great. But when you're
dealing with a general audience,
connection, then you can go into coach.
Another thing, you've got incredible
gestures. We've got to be careful of
gestures like this.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Only reason I say this, but
everybody sometimes looks at this and
thinks, "Mr. Burns."
>> Mhm.
>> Right? And there's a slight nature to
that that causes people to feel like
you're more dominant.
>> Mhm.
>> Which it's okay if there's a moment that
makes sense for you to do that. This was
generally a bit of a default to come
back to. Be careful of that.
>> Okay.
>> Second thing to mention, there's one
move you do. What do you think you do
that might make the audience feel
smaller? What do you think that is?
>> Pointing.
>> No, no, no, no. That's very powerful.
You scared the crap out of that guy, but
that was great. Right? I'll show you
exactly what it is.
It's when we do this.
Okay? Now, the reason this is, what do
you associate What do What do you
associate this with? Who do you normally
do that with?
>> Uh children. Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> Children.
>> Okay. Be careful of that gesture. There
are non-functional gestures that we all
do. When you do that normally without
going into coach archetype, doesn't
create that energy. But when you're in
coach archetype and then you go to this,
this universally speaks, "Oh, you're
you're kind of talking to me like a
kid." Without you intentionally doing
it.
>> Makes sense. Yeah.
>> Right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, you are so good at what you do with
everything else. This is very high-level
feedback. Your gestures are very
polished. And this is strange because
you're so far in the learning process,
you have to back off a bit.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> What creates that stiff nature? Two
things. Body language that is sync on
both sides and always sync. And when
it's always sync like this, people
perceive it as at times at with the game
we're playing now, overly polished.
>> Mhm.
>> So, you need to balance it. It's called
plan spontaneity.
>> Okay.
>> So, you go, "Oh, hey everyone. I I was
in university and
oh, I remember
You get what I'm saying there?
>> I got it. I got
It's 2018 and I'm about to graduate
university and I'm actually
I'm a bit unsure of myself cuz I had
>> Good.
>> I had an assignment I had to complete
tomorrow
and I was a little scared cuz it was
worth 40% of the grade. I'm like, "What
if I fail?"
>> Big round of applause. Big round of
applause.
In sales, that's going to completely
change the game.
>> Mhm.
>> Because now you have a different gear
you can move into. Most people have one
gear. Every conversation they have,
they'll be that coach personality. They
don't switch gears.
Whereas what you have the ability now to
to switch gears based on the person
you're speaking to. When you're speaking
to many, depending on the audience in
Australia, we always start with friend.
Very strong context, okay? Otherwise
people feel that little bit of like
>> Makes sense, yeah.
>> The only other thing I want you to try
when you are communicating with an
audience, you want to learn how to use
singular language with singular eye
contact. Where were you looking the
most? Where do you think you're looking
the most?
>> Probably mid.
>> Mid, yes. That's why I went out there to
watch your eye contact.
>> Gotcha.
>> So you stayed here. What makes it feel
more personal is when you're able to
look at different people
and you speak. So I want you to just try
that beginning part again. Friend
archetype. Go.
>> Yep.
>> But singular eye contact with singular
language. And what I mean by singular
language is most people use group
language. You all know what it means.
>> Yeah.
>> Do you you girls and guys and girls get
what I mean? So instead of doing that,
just go, "Have you been through that
before?"
Can Can Can you understand how stressful
that would have been? So you speak to
many as you speak to one. Give that a
try for me.
>> I'm about to graduate university and I
had this really big presentation. I was
a little scared about tomorrow.
I know there's a been a moment in your
life where you've been scared. For me it
was, "What if I failed?"
>> Perfect. That's round of applause.
That's great. That's great.
Two things I'll say here. I want you to
practice one of them.
Number one.
The stage has three places. This is for
any of you if you're doing this, so
that's all of you.
This is backstage, front of stage.
Now, which part of the stage are you
using only?
>> Front.
>> Yes. Okay. So what we want to do is we
always want to start
here.
Why?
Neutral.
Because remember in communication,
anytime anything becomes default, it
becomes non-functional.
So you use the front of the stage when
you really want to drive a point home.
You don't want to be driving the point
all the time.
Because this is the closest point to you
and the audience. So that creates
intensity when you get here.
But here,
it's less intense.
And again, if you go back here again,
it's even less intense. You generally
don't play back here unless they're
doing an exercise. I want you to start
in the middle, only go to the front for
one highlight,
>> Okay.
>> then move back to the center and
continue the story.
>> Simon coming up tomorrow,
and I was a little afraid. What's going
to happen if I fail? See, as a child, I
was this really shy kid.
And I know there's been probably some
moments in your life where you were
afraid that you may fail. This was mine.
>> Amazing. Okay.
>> I I'll lean forward again. I just put
that
>> It's okay. It's okay. It's a default
behavior. But good news for you, you're
extremely coachable. Just from a
learning point that I want you to get
to, your story
that person made you the hero.
>> Mhm.
>> You saved my life. Okay?
So, when we're trying to influence
others, when you want to be aggressive,
you can be the hero.
>> Yeah.
>> When you want to be connection leaned,
you weren't the hero, someone else was
the hero for you.
>> Makes sense.
>> That softens it.
>> Really good advice.
>> Yeah, you're very strong, but you
learned the soft side.
>> Sure.
>> Makes you undefeatable.
>> Let's go, man.
>> Well done. Big round of applause for
Anthony. Good.
>> Thank you.